der 24 Februar 2022 markiert eine
Zeitenwende in der Geschichte unseres
Kontinents
das ist neu diese Dimension ist neu das
macht den Leuten Angst und sie fordern
mehr für Verteidigung auszugeben
[Musik]
wir müssen jetzt liefern das ist der
entscheidende Punkt wir bekommen die
Aufträge jetzt gerade auch in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
der russische Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine dauert nun schon fast eineinhalb
Jahre und er hat vieles verändert in der
Politik in der Weltwirtschaft und vor
allem in den Köpfen der Menschen
dabei kommt es zu Bildern die vor dem
Krieg kaum denkbar waren Politik und
Rüstung und Öffentlichkeit an einem Ort
der Rüstungskonzern reinmetall baut eine
Fabrik in Weeze an der holländischen
Grenze der Spatenstich wurde öffentlich
zelebriert und rein metallchef Armin
papperger dabei eingerahmt vom NRW
Ministerpräsidenten Hendrik wüst und der
Wirtschaftsministerin Mona Neubauer
drei zwei sprach bei der Eröffnung von
einer mentalen Zeitenwende sollen wir
ehrlich es hat nicht nur in den letzten
30 Jahren eine solche Investition nicht
gegeben in dieser Dimension in Rüstung
es hat auch die Zustimmung dazu in der
Gesellschaft kaum gegeben
wir haben uns alle lange geleistet ein
Stück weit auch ein Bogen Umrüstung zu
machen
seine grüne Wirtschaftsministerin
Neubauer sprachsätze die aus grünem Mund
sehr ungewöhnlich
klingenministerin vor ihnen und
vielleicht ist das auch ein ganz gutes
Signal was eigentlich passiert ist durch
den russischen Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine das eine ja es ist kein
Geheimnis für Sie grüne
industrieministerin hier steht und sagt
Danke schön dass Sie diese Entscheidung
für Rüstungsindustrie in
Nordrhein-Westfalen hier in Weeze
getätigt haben
rein Metall wird am Regionalflughafen
Weeze eine Teilefertigung aufbauen für
den amerikanischen Tarnkappenbomber F35
bis zu 2000 Arbeitsplätze könnten
zusammen mit Zulieferern entstehen das
Kampfflugzeug soll auch den deutschen
Tornado ablösen die Bundeswehr hat
bereits 35 Maschinen bestellt
wir müssen jetzt liefern das ist der
entscheidende Punkt wir bekommen die
Aufträge jetzt gerade auch in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
ministerpistorius macht ernst er er
zieht das jetzt alles durch wie
investieren jetzt hier eine
Größenordnung von über 200 Millionen
Euro in Weeze das war diese Mittelteil
der F35 fertigen können
Rheinmetall ist wie andere
Rüstungskonzerne auch auf der
wirtschaftlichen Überholspur
Verantwortung übernehmen in einer Welt
die sich verändert so sieht das der
Konzern aus seiner Homepage
der Auftragsbestand ist auf Rekordniveau
und der ohnehin schon gestiegene Umsatz
soll in diesem Jahr auf bis zu 7,6
Milliarden Euro steigen
rein Metall hat es in diesem Jahr sogar
in den DAX-Index der Deutschen Börse
geschafft vom batguide zum good guy da
läutete Vorstandschef Papa Ärger zur
Börseneröffnung gerne die Glocke sein
Konzern wurde lange Jahre auch von der
Politik stiefmütterlich behandeln
ärgern kann einen so etwas aber ich war
ich bin seit 25 Jahren oder 30 Jahren
überzeugt davon dass es richtig ist was
wir machen für Demokratie und für die
für den Frieden und auch letztendlich
für die Freiheit unseres Landes zu
kämpfen und ich freue mich heute
wahnsinnig dass meine Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter eigentlich den Lohn
kriegen den sie die letzten 25 Jahre
verdient hätten lass uns nicht
zurückschauen lassen nach vorne schauen
ist gut dass jetzt Tempo draufkommt dass
wir unsere Verteidigungsfähigkeit
stärken und deswegen ist das eine gute
Entscheidung hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen
diese Fabrik zu bauen die Kritik
anrüstungskonzernenmetall ist leise
geworden im letzten Jahr demonstrierten
noch etwas 50 Menschen vor der
Düsseldorfer Firmenzentrale von den
Bundestagsparteien äußern sich nur die
linke und die AFD kritisch
wir fürchten dass das wirklich ein ja
ganz gefährlicher Irrweg ist weil die
Frage ist doch wohin soll das führen
wenn man immer schwerere Waffen liefert
was ist eigentlich das Kriegsziel und
wie kann verhindert werden dass
Deutschland oder die NATO direkt
Kriegspartei wird wir müssen versuchen
diplomatisch alles in die Wege zu leiten
das ist die Aufgabe auch der
Bundesregierung hier auch dafür sorgt zu
tragen auch das zu versuchen ich erkenne
überhaupt keine Versuche ja ich sehe nur
noch Frau Zimmermann wie sie die
nächsten Panzer Panzerlieferungen schon
wieder fordert und auch aus der FDP
heraus die Stimmung bei den Deutschen
ist nach Studien allerdings eine andere
der Wissenschaftler Timo Graf vom
Zentrum für Militärgeschichte und
Sozialwissenschaften der Bundeswehr
untersucht in jedem Jahr die
sicherheitspolitischen Befindlichkeiten
hierzulande die Studie ist eine
repräsentative Stichprobe und wird von
einem unabhängigen Institut durchgeführt
der Ukraine Krieg eine Zäsur
die deutschen sehen sich jetzt
tatsächlich existenziell bedroht durch
militärische Konflikte durch den Krieg
in Europa ein riesengroßen Landkrieg mit
10.000 100.000 Toten das ist neu diese
Dimension ist neu das macht den Leuten
Angst und sie fordern mehr für
Verteidigung auszugeben
die Studie wird seit 1996 durchgeführt
eine der Fragen stimmt die Bevölkerung
zu dass die Ausgaben für Ausrüstung und
Personal der Bundeswehr erhöht werden
klar zu sehen immer dann wenn ein
weltpolitisches Ereignis als Bedrohung
empfunden wird steigt die Zustimmung
rapide nach den Terroranschlägen vom 11
September
nach der Krim Annexion 2014
und nach Beginn des Ukraine Kriegs
die aktuelle Zustimmung zur Erhöhung der
Verteidigungsausgaben und so Zahl der
Soldaten Soldaten der Bundeswehr ist ein
historischer Rekordwert so hohe Werte
haben wir noch nie gemessen
parallel dazu steigt auch die Angst vor
Russland massiv an
die bedrohungswahrnehmung durch Russland
die hat sich massiv verändert die war
sehr ambivalent ausgeprägt in der
Vergangenheit sie hatten maximal ein
Drittel die Russland als Bedrohung für
die Sicherheit Deutschlands erkannt
haben wir liegen da jetzt im Bereich von
annähern 70%. das eine massive
Veränderung die haben wir so in der
Vergangenheit noch nie gesehen
prozentual Sonne starke Veränderung die
Studie fragt auch nach der Zustimmung zu
Waffenexporten an befreundete Staaten
das Verhältnis zwischen Zustimmung und
Ablehnung hat sich nach Beginn des
Ukraine Kriegs umgekehrt eine Mehrheit
ist nun für Waffenlieferungen
das 100 Milliarden Euro schwere
Sondervermögen der Bundesregierung soll
nun in die Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr
fließen auch das NATO Ziel das 2% des
bundeslandsprodukts in die
Verteidigungsausgaben fließen sollen
soll erreicht werden allerdings die
Kapazitäten in Deutschland sind wohl zu
gering
generell ist es so dass unsere
Produktionskapazitäten viel zu niedrig
sind also wenn wir die Bundeswehr
ausstatten wollen so dass sie nicht erst
im Jahr 20140 sondern schnell
einsatzbereit wird wenn wir gleichzeitig
die Ukraine unterstützen wollen unsere
Verpflichtungen in der NATO erfüllen
wollen da brauchen wir viel höhere
Produktionskapazitäten das zum Beispiel
die Munition in zwei Jahren produziert
werden kann nicht in 20 Jahren dafür
braucht man neue Fertigungskapazitäten
und dann müssen eben neue Werke gebaut
werden die Industrie hatte sich das kann
man auch verstehen darauf eingestellt
dass die Verteidigungsausgaben geringer
sind und dann hält man natürlich nicht
solche Kapazitäten vordauer hat
Rheinmetall will auch in der Ukraine
selbst produzieren Panzer vor Ort bauen
zusammen mit dem Staatskonzern
wir wollen die Ukraine dauerhaft
unterstützen damit sie sich selbst
verteidigen kann das ist auch die
einzige der einzige Weg den es gibt bis
die Ukraine NATO mitglied werden kann
dafür muss man ständig Militärgüter in
die Ukraine liefern oder man muss sie
eben da produzieren die Ukraine ist ein
leichte leistungsfähiges Technologieland
mit sehr qualifizierten Arbeitskräften
insofern halte ich das für eine logische
Entwicklung dass man auch darüber
nachdenkt dort Produktionskosten
Skalieren oder Dinge die wir sowieso für
die Ukraine produzieren wollen gleich
dort herzustellen
der Imagewandel der Rüstungsindustrie
die vor dem ukrainekrieg eher im
Schatten da sein ihre Geschäfte machte
und nun gerne auch von der Politik
hofiert wird der Spatenstich in Weeze
hatte so auch etwas von
Goldgräberstimmung
drei zwei eins ja